let me pull up this story we'll get
we'll start gonna get into more hard
politics it's from the daily mail two
russian fighter jets that violated
swedish airspace earlier this month were
equipped with nukes
with the aim of scaring stockholm
you know it's certainly a story you
could lead with for a show like oh
russia deployed nukes at this point i am
desensitized to to these stories and we
talked about it yesterday vladimir putin
reportedly you know travels to nuclear
bunker and as we're getting into it i'm
just like yo i am i am desensitized to
this they have fear-mongered and
screamed and banged on things to the
point where i'm like whatever dude i got
a bucket full of beans
i'm not gonna cry and complain about it
and what do we even say when every day
they're trying to push some some you
know ukraine war joe biden like well you
know what's sad is the minute i saw that
i i didn't believe it because you know
i'm just kind of at that point where i'm
numb to it and i feel like we've been
told so many lies by the same people for
so long and every time you bite and
believe them
you end up really regretting it i mean
and so i my first question is what's the
intelligence on that who who said that
this is the fact
you know yeah who knows what their aim
was i mean you'd have to have russian
intelligence confirming yeah you would
have to or have some sort of visual
confirmation i didn't read the story so
i don't know what they're saying is
backing up this claim but they're just
reporting it it's them it's their their
their their intelligence yeah and i have
no i have no respect for it at this
point you know there's there's nothing i
can
say except for that i you know you it
can't even assume it's true it has
emerged it has emerged emerged from
where
this is like the loch ness monster
is this company daily mail like a shock
content because i i see
interesting stuff come out of daily mail
it's sort of people don't report yeah
you get like
joe threatens and it's like well i mean
he he was warning i thought it was more
of a warning but they they phrased this
as a threat they're a little bombastic
yeah okay that's a little bombastic but
there's real there's real stuff there
yeah sometimes i think they don't go far
enough in how they describe things
sometimes i think they frame it wrong
sometimes i think they go too far yeah
but you know that's what it is is that
newsguard give a hundred no not a
hundred i mean maybe actually we'll see
that's 16 did i try to teach my own kids
about consuming media and news in
general is that they need to do what tim
just did
you know like critically think about
what each one of these places you're
reading from actually does what do they
do what are the mistakes they make so
that when you're consuming the
information you can do so in a manner
where you can kind of parse out
this might actually not be wholly
accurate but they're pretty good with
this stuff so that's probably true and
then go to somewhere else that is good
with the stuff they're not good with and
you can kind of fuse it together for
a real understanding of what you're
probably getting you can be real though
let's be real
if right now i got a cnn alert on my
phone or
a video from cnn went on all the tvs or
wherever and it was brian stelter
himself saying ladies and gentlemen a
nuclear missile was fired from russia
and is currently heading towards the
north to to towards the united states
i believe it
if if cnn came out on tv and brian
sutter said and icbm has been fired and
it's being tracked and headed towards
the us
i would believe it well i should put it
this way i would act as though it were
true is a better way to put it
i don't know you know if that potato
went on tv and said my birthday was
february 27th i probably wouldn't
believe it
even though it is my birthday but but
that's different
like we're talking about
a missile headed towards the us maybe
jake tapper i'd believe it if it was
jake tapper maybe i'd believe it it was
good like he wouldn't lie about that
he'd lie about a lot of other stuff but
maybe not that i like that you phrased
it as you would act as though it were
true not necessarily believe in facebook
but take evasive action if someone's
going to go on national tv make that
claim that's a big enough claim for me
personally to take seriously regardless
of where probably was probably wise in
the case of a nuke i'll give you that
but if he said it about a virus i'd be
like no i'm not i'm not buying any
non-immediate thing i'm not gonna make a
snap i'm not gonna jump to activity
because of what cnn just told me yeah i
mean if if brian stelter you know posted
a twitter video and he said
intelligence was reporting and icbm
headed towards the east coast i'd be out
the door and i'd be like let's go to our
secure location and act as though it's
true
and then if he comes out later and he's
like whoopsie i was watching war games
or what was that what's that movie
matthew broderick yeah war games yeah
talk about burying the lead i'm pretty
sure you just confirmed you have a
nuclear bunker well i didn't say nuclear
bunker but we have a security i mean you
kind of you kind of inferred
possibly or implied nuclear bunkers
i'm not entirely sure can withstand a
nuclear blast would you guys ever move
into one of those bunkers where they
launched like space shuttles out of and
stuff you mean that i move into it just
yeah an old silo yeah like live there
no i have a beautiful farm so i'd stay
there i'm staying i'm staying on the
farm what about under your farm but
nobody yes in a nuclear war oh
absolutely i could so i could survive
anywhere if i had my wife my kids and my
my dogs i'm happy it doesn't matter
where i am you can buy nuclear uh icbms
uh uh silos missile silos they're not
necessarily nuclear scientists and
there's like 16 floors yeah that's what
i was thinking of but you if you set up
the farm up top you you go down and you
have this big cylindrical uh
it looks like really cool but i think
that's more fantasy when you get there
it's all grungy and like yeah
it sounds like a great idea until you
smell it right so you probably see the
sun i know and you get vitamin d
deficiency yeah impressed in my world my
gosh man these these dystopian sci-fi
movies where people are in like this
underground room with tv screens for
windows
and they're like we're there basically
you know what's amazing how many people
have vitamin d deficiencies i know
that's totally off topic but i was just
talking about that with somebody the
other day it is incredible the number of
people who don't get the right stuff
that their body needs i was also like if
you could somehow get sunlight
underground with mirrors yeah all the
way in your business you lose fidelity
on every time it bounces off the mirror
so you have to use like sound to guide
the light and you might be able to guide
light down tunnels with sound so you
could like have daylight underground
with sound
sound waves can can uh guide photons
without interference as much as
interference as they found with matter
it's got to be an immense amount of
energy i'd imagine right probably i'm
sure i don't know that much about it use
mirrors and i don't want to take away
from your vitamin d talk because that's
super i've actually been taking a
vitamin d supplement yeah me too
store lately vitamin d and vitamin k i
think it is from jones himself mr jones
mine's from my doctor mine's for my
doctor but it's uh it's therapeutic
because i feel like people need to
really boost this stuff it gives you so
much energy makes you feel so healthy
you know i'm not making a
go talk to your medical person about it
you know
yeah it's so good for you oh my gosh i
was just in washington state over the
weekend and the sun was amazing because
it's not like a des it's kind of a
desert it's like a mountain desert man
that's sunlight just nonstop yeah i
would highly recommend if you haven't
been on this vitamin d is underrated big
time big time underrated people you get
sick you know i remember when i was uh
younger i'd ask people like how come
you don't really see like
pets getting sick as often as people do
yeah and maybe it's not true for some
people maybe you get a dog with sick all
the time but i remember growing up our
dog was almost never sick with anything
and it's like well maybe because the dog
doesn't interact with other dogs and
humans interact with other humans that's
a good story when dogs do weird stuff
too like sometimes you'll find them like
nibbling on a rock or something like
that it's because they actually can kind
of search out what they need and they'll
get the minerals somehow they're going
to try to find it and their body just
knows you know and i think that's why
you see that you know they're they're
they're funny little furry creatures
they're smart they can smell
cancer they can smell strokes think
about how incredible that is dogs can
smell sniff out cancer that's crazy wow
incredible yeah oh wow i wonder what
that or smelling the stroke before it
happens yeah or a seizure of a seizure
wow yeah there's videos where like
someone's about to seize their epileptic
and they catch them yeah the dog will
jump on them and then lay down and then
they'll be like uh oh and then they'll
start yeah unless it's the dog causing
the seizure oh yeah well that's that's a
new conspiracy i haven't heard that one
it's the word god spelled backwards you
think that's on purpose he's well
they're god's gift to us you know so
maybe maybe that's his way of letting us
know this is my gift to you because
there's nothing better than dogs we've
got great danes and they're the best
animals anybody who's ever like been
confused about what type of dog they get
get a great dane they're the best even
in an apartment they don't love exercise
as much as people would think they're
couch potatoes but they will give you so
much love
i have kind of a i don't have a hate
relationship i'm not a love hate that's
a little extreme i got bit by a dog when
i was a bait like six i went it was
playing with it was eating and i got
close too close to it and it jumped up
and bit my face and ripped off i'd get
stitches and like it was really
traumatic so i've kind of had like a
distrust of dogs in general like i don't
i think they're psychopaths that was in
fact actually a democrat in that dogs
they were just dogs yeah no it's a
democrat in a dog suit so you're
distrusting the wrong person who's no
longer a democrat yeah
it was a young adam schiff i think a
joke by the way
once you learn how to like the dog's
language and you know don't get your
face next to it while it's eating if you
know some basic dog things i think
they're phenomenal oh they're fantastic
like our dogs i i was telling lydia
earlier actually like i trust my dogs
more than humans you know with my kids
there's certain people where i was like
if you had to leave them with the great
dane or that person who would you leave
them with and i'm like probably a great
dane most of the time you know they do
they do the job a little bit better
kind of crazy how we went from two
russian fighter jets
to dogs
of dogs and families well somehow we
went to vitamin d and then dogs and
living underground nuclear war is that
what this because you're going to need a
dog babysitter in nuclear war if you're
in a bunker just so you can get five
minutes also vitamin d supplements yes
yes you're definitely going to need
those we really wrap that up i think
this is all no okay
fear propaganda all the all the war junk
i've heard that is is ukraine actually
gonna succeed don bass in the eastern
region that's what they're saying i
think they have to for this to end you
know i think that's where it said wait
was it that russia's seeding those back
to ukraine no no definitely not no they
keeps reporting how russia is losing but
then how zolensky saying okay
we're gonna make concessions and give
you what you want
i do think that's where we're headed i
think probably two three weeks they'll
have a final deal that's just my you
know not based on any intelligence or
anything else just my my gut feeling on
this in that situation there i think
they're going to have to give that area
up because in reality well russia wants
a buffer
and you know they're not going to stop
making everybody's lives hell until they
get that buffer and i think that with
the administration we have they know
we're toothless we're not going to do
anything you know they're just going to
go and take what they want thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there